I've been googling narcissism all day
I've been denied I'm gonna think you are
I don't think I'm gonna show you a
questionnaire let's just you want to go
through it I can tell you I've known you
forever I don't think you're a nurse
yeah in fact I think you're the opposite
I think that you are you may be
self-destructive and you may have set
low self-esteem all the good things that
kamek needs yeah but I don't think that
you're a narcissist no in fact and I'll
tell you you will always go out of your
way to try to empower other people
that's what I thought always thought
about myself I know but she disagrees
with you I not only do I disagree I
think you are the prototype for
narcissism like you are the exact if you
just read the book Bobby your phone's
right it's wise my grow is my Steve's
girlfriend calling me because your thing
is attached to her yeah I don't want to
[ __ ] it but here's the questions
alright let me go to the questions
alright the first one is you like to be
the center of attention that's that just
means you're a performer it means you're
a [ __ ] comic and you and you love the
sensation of you happen to have a skill
set that's very rare which is you can
make people double over in laughter okay
right so you're really good at it I make
a point yeah narcissists are very good
in their work field they're charming
they're well-liked from from from a
distance but they're very difficult to
live with that's okay but that's not the
way to define a narcissist a narcissist
is the hero or the victim of every story
he tells okay there we go
and that man Bobby tells plenty of
stories about other people in fact the
focus is usually on other people so I am
at I'm a doctor and everybody in this
the first thing he already answered it
so I I don't
this is apply to me all right because
I'm a comic and I need to make people
laugh yeah you have a habit of giving
unsolicited advice that's ridiculous
yeah that's a ridiculous notion though
to say that somebody's that narcissistic
that I don't I reject that trying to
help people right so let's say Gilbert
and I write
you're wearing a comedy club and you're
listening in right let's talk about
something about our lives okay okay yes
so that rash you have I mean it's
killing me man
yeah it's like been bleeding and I keep
scratching it right well maybe that's
and then would you see now you're
already listening right and I like the
way you're listening and I saw your your
brow not which means you're actually
concerned for him so you know what yeah
so there's another one here here's
another one my friends you to test
waiting in line oh [ __ ] off where's this
from me health go [ __ ] yourself I don't
wait in line so [ __ ] you you know what I
do
my dad was waiting in line we had to go
to holiday twelve of us and I was like
I'm not waiting in the sighs at
LaGuardia it was the JFK but the line
was literally around the block yeah I'll
[ __ ] you guys I gotta go give me a
hundred bucks you guys wanna go give me
a hundred bucks right now yeah hundred
bucks I go to the guy who's the front
line I go bro listen I got a question
for shake his hand first off it's good
to see ya hundred dollars I can't
physically wait in this line Yeah right
that's all people he goes give me a
second and that was it we got on the
plane so shut the [ __ ] up right called
that's called just getting people on a
plane
Zak exactly right right I was on the
plane from Baltimore to here yesterday
all right I paid I don't I didn't tell
you this but I paid for a first-class
350 or something that's how I do it yeah
if it's available right I took it right
I fly privately but keep going I don't
have a plane yet right it doesn't matter
right so I'm sitting there and this
actually happened um there was a group
they go you know who goes before our
first class who goes on the plane before
right so a couple of kids went on that's
fine a couple of military guys thank you
for your service and then a whole
baseball team goes on that would annoy
me right and they're wearing red hoodies
and their kids or high school and I sit
out loud what the hell is this right and
then the coach looks at me goes they're
hearing impaired right and I go oh [ __ ]
right yeah and so that I had a red
hoodie to it the same day it did but as
I was next rise first
so I'm behind them and then the
stewardess looks at me she goes welcome
and I burst into laughter I said I've
been a part of them I've got a part I do
this these guys these two thugs got
really mad at me cuz I cut him off and
they were in pickup and they wanted to
fight they were young and they were
there was just ready to go and I was
like these guys are [ __ ] tough I
can't fight these two guys and they go
they made the guy he goes that's your
ass you [ __ ] or something like
that yeah and I went I just looked at my
entire Canyon you very well if I can do
it may come up with something different
hey man you double parked in my spot oh
that's so bad hey man you parked your
car two spots so stereotypical girl I
didn't know I could retort in [ __ ]
Asian oh it sound like you had been you
had been like you were trapped under
rubble all right do you demolish
something I got to take more classes
from your buddy
okay here's some work things then your
ambition knows no bound no no I'm doing
this list [ __ ] I mean maybe my love my
love I don't want to say that you're in
the National swim team yeah I'm sorry
because I'm gonna call you that again
we're gonna do about the dog barking I
don't know leave it there you know how
to turn on the charm this could be
Buzzy's one because this is more my
thing because I say no to all of these
ones yours yours I say yes - all right
go go to your list babe
okay yeah shame sir humiliates those who
agree disagree with him and often goes
in the attack when hurt or frustrated
exploding with rage how about throwing
tantrums or even breaking laws with
minimal consequences okay here's the
thing saying that because I don't pay
for parking tickets or like if I get one
I'll just speed up and let the fly off I
know that's not true what sir have you
racked up a lot of parking tickets I
have and they told my car and tell it
even when I had no money I just go ahead
and tow it because I always feel like
regular rules don't apply your comic
yeah so what do you do then just pay the
huge fine when they yeah like I didn't
pay taxes until I was like 35 and then I
owed them like three hundred thousand
dollars but I just I keep it to that
limit oh yeah and then I go oh I don't
wanna go to jail so then I'll pay see
that's not a narcissist yeah that's
that's I have one more wiser distorts
the truth for personal gain blames
others there makes excuse yeah I'm I'll
tell you what is my job as a comedian
yeah I have to exaggerate story
embellish embellish when I tell jokes
onstage right it's not the complete and
utter truth then it wouldn't be funny
you you you lie a little bit you
exaggerate and whatnot for air tamer
purposes get away from you know the
consequences that's what it's saying we
mean I don't have what do you mean
consequence not onstage not when I steal
jewels I say I can't see I did it bags
yeah I did a crime before
[Music]